the foxnews sexual harassment scandal
has escalated even more and it now has
pulled in bill o'reilly as well as
former host andrea tantaros i'll give
you the background it started with a
lawsuit from former host gretchen
carlson who alleged she was sexually
harassed and asked to do all sorts of
things by Roger Ailes in order to
continue her position on the network she
says that it was basically a boys club
misogynist sexual harassment totally
normalized sexual harassment situation
twenty other women then came out of the
woodwork megyn kelly jumped into the
fray saying yeah this actually does
happen and it led to Fox News chief
Roger Ailes resigning in shame but with
a very very nice reportedly forty
million dollar golden parachute the
latest is that former for Fox News hosts
andrea tantaros a right winger a
conservative talker not someone we can
write off as some kind of safe space
Gloria Allred third wave feminists right
we're talking Louis here about a right
winger she is now filed a major lawsuit
where she claims that Roger Ailes
sexually harassed her that other
high-ranking executives created a
culture of persistently abusive behavior
and and this is where it starts to get
even more interesting it mentions Bill
O'Reilly asserting that Bill O'Reilly
once asked tantaros to stay with him at
a quote very private place in Long
Island and expressed a desire to see her
as a wild girl the lawsuit also mentions
former Massachusetts Republican Senator
Scott Brown who tantaros alleges made
sexually inappropriate comments about
her including once grabbing her around
the waist when she was buying lunch
Scott Brown responded to this where else
but Twitter saying as a survivor of
sexual abuse I would never perpetuate
language or actions as described in the
Fox complaint the actions referenced are
fabricated listen if sexual harassment
and misogyny at Fox News surprise you
you're probably uninformed enough to be
a regular Fox News viewer that there's
nothing at all surprising about the
Louis or your work for Fox News but but
the people who work for Fox News are
some of the ones making the complaints
here and these are people who have been
with the company for a long time what's
what's the goal here they're well-paid
right I mean well although there are
some Fox News staffers according to
CNN's brian Stelter whose claims to have
spoken to some Fox News staffers on the
condition of anonymity they feel that
the allegations made by tantaros are
sort of exaggerated they're not totally
buying it not really proof of anything
we have we have allegations we have a
resignation we have 22 women at this
point who have similar stories now if
you're surprised or shocked that Bill
O'Reilly is mentioned recall that he has
had sexual harassment problems of his
own settling a very high profile sexual
harassment lawsuit leveled in 2004 by a
producer named Andrea Makris for
reportedly more than two million dollars
in order to avoid having to admit any
wrongdoing he was charged with talking
to his producer about his personal
sexual fantasies his masturbation her
masturbation vibrators sometimes
reportedly appearing to be pleasuring
himself during the conversations with
Angie or Andrea Makris this is all so
confusing to me Lois since Fox News is
the only news network that's really
advocating Christian morality and
Christian principles it's shocking to me
that they would have these issues Dave
are you being sarcastic yes you might
you might be being a little sarcastic so
to summarize the full list of andrea
tantaros claims i'll put this list up
for you to take a look at
she says that Roger Ailes allegedly
would refer to Fox News host as gay so
fat and a Puerto Rican [ __ ] in one case
as I mentioned suggests that Bill
O'Reilly allegedly suggested a private
meeting as his home to see to see his to
see her wild side she made these Scott
Brown allegations that he made sexually
suggestive remarks on set and also
touched her in a way she didn't like
also claiming that Fox News ran their PR
machine with an aggressive campaign to
smear her once she started complaining
and Fox executive bill shine allegedly
advised and reattempt our
- just let the allegations go we will
see where this leads this does not seem
to be going away Louis we thought well
maybe with the Ailes resignation it'll
go away but we've actually seen it
become an even bigger story since then I
can't imagine there are many more people
waiting in the board work to come out
and you think the 22 might be the full
lot of them it could be yeah but that's
substantial ultimately is this going to
to hurt Fox News and and lower
viewership no I think a lot of their
viewers will chalk it up to a liberal
media conspiracy or something yeah yeah
or just some type of misogynistic excuse
oh yeah they've actually already it's
funny I've noticed other corporate media
outlets they do mention this story
sometimes but they're pretty light about
it almost like they say we're gonna play
kind of nice with the other networks and
it's actually making it even harder to
make the case that this is all a
so-called liberal media smear because
actually corporate media has been sort
of light handed on this yeah well if I
had to guess I'd say that this is
happening in far more places than just
fox news studios yeah well that would be
another reason why other media outlets
may want not want to be too harsh
because they may not want the
investigations turned on to them after
the break we will speak to the great
Chris Martenson it's been a couple years
since he's been on and I really look
forward to speaking with him